[Laughter]
why is his tongue sticking out like that
oh no this is the side of parrots you
never thought you'd see
[Laughter]
g'day i'm anne from abc science and
today we're going to be breaking down
videos of extraordinary animal behavior
from surprising skills choose mate to
super senses
we've searched the internet to find the
best videos to show which of these five
wild animals is the most extraordinary
[Music]
yeah wow
[Applause]
[Music]
if there was a prize for breaking the
internet these animals would probably
win it yes
we're going to talk about goats
gates
[Music]
oh they look so handsome when they're up
there like that don't they
it looks like an art piece
actually quite good climbers as you can
see
and in morocco it's become a little bit
famous for having goats that climb trees
in particular argan trees now you might
use some of that oil in your beauty
regime like in your hair or something it
actually comes from a seed and 60 of
that has been chewed by a goat you do
see goats climbing trees but why there
are like 15 goats in a tree in this case
i i don't know and it may be a tourist
thing or something but it's definitely
an important part of their diet and uh
your beauty regime
look at that
these look like juveniles like young
ones look at their little hookies
okay i'm going to
what a cool creature
ibex can be found across
europe northern africa and across asia
in mountainous areas they can jump
something like 1.8 meters straight up
without a run-up
whoop
guys making my knees ache just looking
at it the ibex are incredible climbers
and to enable them to do that they've
got some really specialized feet so
they've got two
toes that are like little hoofy things
but they can move independently and that
creates the ability for them to actually
grip onto uneven surfaces but on top of
that they've got a sort of hard section
and a soft section that's concave
and that means that they're sort of like
little suction cups like they're not
good enough that they're going to be
able to stick to a window but they're
definitely good enough that they're
going to be able to go up an almost
sheer cliff face and be able to grip as
they go
[Music]
why is his tongue sticking out like that
[Music]
this handsome chap appears to be
doing a mating call
he's really advertising his virility or
something similar
one study found that in terms of their
vocal behavior that is their
communication between each other kids
that were brought up together had much
more similar accents than kids that were
brought up separately this sort of thing
helps with group cohesion so if you've
got an accent that indicates you're from
melbourne you are going to have
solidarity with other people from
melbourne and it's sort of similar with
the goats
[Music]
look at those fancy horns i reckon you
can see a reflection of himself and he
thinks that his reflection is
competition
this goat is a marco marco is a
combination of two different words and
it means snake eater
they're absolutely gorgeous these are
really really rare
goats there's hardly any of these macaws
left in the wild they're native to sort
of central asia right up high in the
mountains
what's up dude the horns are just
spectacular they grow something like 1.5
meters long
1.5 meters hanging off the back of your
head can you imagine like i mean i get a
neck ache when i wear my binoculars
around my neck
ah
okay
oops
[Music]
all right okay there is a lot going on
there right there's a puppy chasing a
fawn but then the goat appears to get
into the game but then fall over right
this is a breed of goat called a
myotonic goat you might have heard of it
as the tennessee fainting goat because
it looks like it's
had its smelling salts
and fallen over
when they get a fright there's like a
glitch their muscles go really tense and
they just fall over this is a congenital
condition it's like a recessive gene in
the case of these startling goats this
is something that we're doing as we
breed the goats for these particular
traits but i don't think that when i got
a fright that i would want to be
incapacitated and you know maybe it's
the same for the goats as well
oh my goodness look how little they are
goats are much more socially capable
than you might give them credit for they
did these tests where they put photos of
humans smiling and photos of humans
being sad and grumpy and tried to figure
out which ones the goat wanted to
interact with turns out they really like
to interact with happy humans
so it's not just body language it's
literally facial expression that the
goats can react to
they appear to want cuddles as well
look at how sweet they are
i think goats are extraordinary they've
got some amazing adaptations to their
environment like their little horse but
i think their ability to actually read
our emotions is something that's really
surprising and unique
[Music]
dolphins are probably one of the most
loved animals on the planet but do they
really deserve a place in our heart what
is it that makes them so special
wow
that is so beautiful
[Laughter]
nailed it
i love that that would actually hurt
because they're a pretty big animal
here we go
oh that is so good oh it definitely
means it like it's way too direct for it
to be a mistake when you see it come out
of the water it just like goes
all in one big block
it could be because they thought it was
a threat
it could be because it was funny i
suppose the truth of the matter is is
that dolphins are actually really
socially and emotionally complex
creatures and this is one of the
outcomes of that
love it could that dolphin be a member
of our rugby team representing australia
that was a pretty good tackle see this
is that a dog in the water
oh with a dolphin
that's pretty cool
they're inherently curious creatures so
meeting a creature that it's never met
before that wants to look at it it wants
to sense it it might be thinking this is
the weirdest fish i have ever
echolocated on so echolocating is a
series of clicks that they throw out
into the environment and that echoes
back off objects back to them a
bottlenose dolphin which i assume this
probably is that's the most common
dolphin that you see in the waters
around australia does something like a
thousand clicks a second not only are
they able to sense a target fish in the
water it's able to sense how big the
fish is how far it is away it's
incredible
[Music]
that's amazing
where are they going look they're
creating all of that white water on the
top that's so incredible some people are
really lucky what they get to see
it looks like a washing machine of
dolphins that's so cool dolphins
make huge groups on occasion
it's what's called a fission fusion
society as they you know split off into
smaller family or friendship units
and sometimes you might see them
in literal hundreds or thousands of
dolphins a baby orca
ah no this is not ever gonna be me i'm
never going in the water ever again they
are the scariest animal on earth for me
i don't know why
orcas are the largest of all of the
members of the dolphin family and they
can kill great white sharks they can
gang up on things that are much bigger
than them they can kill like blue whales
these things are freaking incredible
it's hard to tell what's happening here
exactly it could be playful it could be
like slightly aggressive because there's
those smaller orca there
although they're seen as deadly there is
no record of an orca ever killing a
human in the wild generally when you
hear of orca attacks it's from
individuals who are possibly deranged in
captive situations
not in this sort of situation would they
be capable of absolutely tearing apart
that human and swallowing them yes
orcas are a little bit different than
the smaller dolphin species in that orca
young will stay with their mothers in a
female-led pod for basically their
entire life
so beautiful
you'd never ever forget that experience
would you animal encounters can be
absolutely life-changing and i spoke
with rob and nikki house from new
zealand who went out swimming one day
and came across a pot of dolphins it was
kind of like they were charging at us
and then
slapping their tails on the water right
next to us so it was yeah pretty
aggressive wow i thought i was going to
get eaten by dolphins
we had no idea what was going on and
that's when i saw the shark for about
two seconds
as it arcs around us the dolphin just
went ballistic and then literally within
minutes two minutes the dolphins just
suddenly released just relax and in my
own mind i knew that the the threat had
gone it's definitely
an unbeatable experience that's so
amazing i mean these are the sorts of
stories that you hear
um
handed down like folklore so they are
some lucky people not just because the
dolphins protected them and saved their
lives but that they got to be that close
to wild animals that are that smart
very lucky
[Music]
oh is it hurting those fish
look at it it's gonna make a circle look
at this ah so cool
dolphins in florida have a really
special way of catching their dinner
they basically go around and they drag
through the mud and create a muddy
circle which acts like a net right so it
started drawing the circle and the fish
got caught in the middle of the circle
and then basically they're a bit
discombobulated and they can't see where
to go and the dolphin swings in with its
echolocation and eats all the
fish wow
see the fish just panicking
such an ingenious thing
[Music]
so yes dolphins are undeniably awesome
they seem to really enjoy having fun
they communicate with each other in
really complex ways and even though they
have the capacity to kill us they don't
really seem to want to so what what
would you want
and if you're one of the lucky people
that's been out there in the ocean and
got close to a dolphin think yourself
lucky that you get to be close to an
extraordinary being it's probably
smarter than you
[Music]
cheers mate we've got even better videos
to come so stay tuned
[Music]
from disney to dr seuss we've grown up
with heaps of lovable elephants in books
and films but how much do we really know
about wild elephants
okay
oh there's a little baby back there
he knows what he's doing hey
i've never seen an elephant in the wild
but my understanding is the best thing
to do is remain calm and i'd be probably
trying to slowly move away
in a really non-threatening way
look at how big they are
is she leaving
crisis averted
oh oh no
it was just to get a run up
[Music]
wow
she's so powerful and because she's so
close up you get a really good view of
her tusks
these are essentially extensions of
their teeth they're not hollow like
horns they're absolutely beautiful and
solid and it's thought that something
like 30 000 elephants a year are poached
just for
[Music]
ivory that driver is so lucky that he is
unharmed
so this is a demonstration of anxious
elephants we've got trumpeting the tails
are erect the ears are out like this is
all
saying that the elephants are
uncomfortable with the presence of these
humans
big trumpet so when a human is speaking
we as a general rule use about one
octave of sound
elephants use about four octaves of
sounds
[Music]
there are sounds that happen that are
barely perceptible for humans but
elephants can hear them and in the right
conditions they can hear each other over
like 10 kilometers using these amazing
low sounds
these are african elephants
the easiest way to tell essentially
african elephants generally have the
shape of africa as their ears
hey
come on
so amazing that's enough it's hard not
to be in all of them really
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh that would hurt that driver because
those trunks can weigh something like
130 kilograms it's one of the most
complex organs that has ever evolved on
earth it's basically a combination of an
upper lip and a nose as well as fingers
as the elephant's looking around the car
it's smelling everything olaf faction is
a really important part of animal
communication and it is for the
elephants as well
that's so cool no come back mate
[Laughter]
that's terrifying but also very very
very cool
[Laughter]
oh my goodness so itchy
i think it's an asian elephant i can't
tell that from its bum because it's got
small ears
[Laughter]
one of the differences between the asian
and african elephants is the african
elephants have a much more wrinkly skin
and that's because they live in much
drier country and the wrinkles basically
hold on to moisture in the skin
[Music]
that's so cute
it's just flopping around
when they're babies they're a bit
uncoordinated just like baby humans are
with their limbs
oh it's you're so big
oh it's practicing
when they're little they they practice
charging at things like warthogs
it literally sounds like the lion king
when they're born they weigh about 90
kilograms so that's a pretty decent
sized human the thing is they have to be
pretty much ready to go when they come
out right because to access the mother's
milk they really have to be able to
stand up and reach
because the mothers are so big so yeah
they come out pretty much fully formed
and gorgeous
[Applause]
we've got an amazing scene here we've
got a whole group of elephants trying to
cross the river and you can see the
little baby using its trunk as a snorkel
not very successfully because it's
getting in a little bit of distress
but when another elephant shows distress
whether that be physical or emotional
they will help each other
you can see that the other adults
immediately sort of converge and figure
out the issue
the oldest largest females are in
general sort of like the leaders of the
group
they have decades and decades of lived
experience and they can remember where
water holes are where they found lots of
good food where dangerous things happen
places to avoid they've got
incredibly long memories
[Music]
elephants are amazing in every single
sense of the word whether it's their
absolute loyalty to their family group
their ability to problem solve or their
unique anatomy they are
extraordinary in every way
[Music]
camels are weird looking creatures i'm
pretty sure that we can say that but
they make living in the desert look like
a walk in the park
so how do they do that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
pretty sure that white bread isn't good
for camels is that how you think look at
how big its head is
camels are
huge
like 2 2.5 metres high at the hump and
maybe three meters long they are just
enormous
their nostrils are long and flat and can
close over and that's so that they don't
breathe in heaps of heat and sand which
is pretty rad and on top of that their
eyes beautiful eyes they've got really
long eyelashes which is to keep the heat
and the sand out they are perfectly
adapted for that desert environment
ninety percent of the world's camels are
dromedary camels this one humped camel
there are millions of camels worldwide
but most of them are domesticated and
there is no such thing anymore as wild
dromedary camels
oh
[Laughter]
that's pretty cool so these are a
different species of camel these are
bactrian camels and you can tell because
they've got two humps and in fact
there's two species within them there's
one that is a domestic battery and
camera which i'm imagining that these
are but there are wild bacterian camels
and these are the only truly wild camels
left in the world
and they
are
simply amazing they turn into these huge
shaggy monsters in the winter and are
able to withstand well below freezing
they can drink salt water they live in
the gobi desert in mongolia and china
and there are less than a thousand left
which means they're critically
endangered camels are found in some
really weird places that you wouldn't
quite expect like we've got heaps in
australia they're not native here
they're feral that means that they were
once domesticated used as stock animals
or for transport and then were released
or escaped and have made australia home
[Music]
ah that is disgusting
that is a dollar it's essentially a
little fleshy sac that's on the inside
of a male camel's mouth and they can
inflate it with air
when they feel things
yeah so this is a male camel with
feelings
it does have like a sexual element to it
where he's showing off but he can use it
in all sorts of different situations
oh
that's incredible
look at it
inside the lips of a camel
is sort of scary they can eat the most
amazingly prickly and hard things and it
comes down to a whole heap of conical
things that are on the inside of their
lips they're called papillae yeah
they're impartially made of keratin the
same stuff that makes your nails or your
hair and so that's what gives them that
sort of rigidity i don't think that like
prickly pears would probably be the sort
of thing that they
would eat had they been wild because it
does seem like it'd probably be on the
extreme end of things as an adaptation
to living in these hot environments
camels are also able to
lose a lot of water like 30 of the water
in their body if that happened to us we
would carc it right because we can only
lose about 10 of our water mass before
our blood basically becomes too thick
for our heart to pump
when it gets extremely hot a camel can
last something like four to seven days
maybe without drinking but in really
good conditions they can go like 10
months without having a drink
it can drink an incredible amount to
rehydrate itself something like 110
liters in 10 minutes that's 11 liters
a minute
oh is this a stuntman
is he gonna
he's going to leave a camel
oh
yeah roundhouse kick
[Laughter]
yeah
i mean
they're not predators right but they
have ways to defend themselves and if
you're gonna do something annoying like
take a running jump to land on its back
it's yeah it's gonna clock you one
that's good timing though isn't it and
right on the knees
vicious
so there you have it camels are bizarre
but despite the fact that they do all of
this weird stuff they are really amazing
at surviving in the world's harshest
environment and for that reason they are
extraordinary
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
the kia is a new zealand parrot that is
being nicknamed the clown of the
mountains but why is it that something
that likes having fun so much can live
in the freezing cold
hey mate got a job for you
she might
[Laughter]
can you give us a hand
cheers mate
[Laughter]
that's
amazing so here are what's called
neophilic and
before you get worried it actually means
that they're attracted to new things
they like to have new experiences so
they're really curious so they're going
to do things like open a bottle of beer
for you
the beak on the kia is so amazing for a
parrot in fact some people have called
it the swiss army knife of beaks because
it can basically do everything wildcare
are found on the south island of new
zealand and only there in the world
they're really really special birds
look at it
god they're so cool
[Laughter]
in certain parts of new zealand right up
in the alpine areas where the kia are
native
they are attracted to vehicles because
at some point someone has fed them from
a vehicle perhaps they think there's
food inside there or they're just having
fun
oh it gets it right at the end
[Music]
that's so good
that's so good i mean it's sad for any
radio listening i suppose but apart from
that
you can see a little bit of the
iridescence on the wing and in their
underwing cart is this amazing patch of
like scarletty red it's just absolutely
gorgeous kias are now protected because
they're an endangered species and it's
thought that these days there's only
like three to seven thousand kia left in
the wild which isn't that many
i mean it's a lot of car aerials though
isn't it
[Music]
it works for the council
oh is it putting them out to try and
stop cars
oh my god they're so smart
look at it
because then when you stop a car you can
start to attack the car until someone
gives you a sandwich
oh i love these birds
with dragging pushing pulling one of the
strategies to get around this sort of
kia damage has been to create
playgrounds for them next to stopping
points like this
they put a kia gym right there and it's
got things for them to swing on and spin
around in movable bits to try and keep
them off the cars because they just
love new things they love to play
hello nighttime kia oh no
this is the side of parrots you never
thought
you'd see
under the cover of darkness the kias
will go up to a flock
and they'll take some chunks out of the
hindquarters of sheep
it's pretty gory stuff and back in the
earlier colonial days they would pay
people to go out and kill the kias
because they thought that they were
murdering heaps and heaps of sheep
now you might wonder why keel would do
this well
it's really high in fats and all the
protein that you need especially if you
live at a high altitude and you've got a
chick in the nest but these attacks are
extremely uncommon and rarely fatal it's
generally from an infection from the
wound and that doesn't happen so much
anymore sometimes kia can just sort of
like ride around and be playing on the
back of a sheep
so i don't think they're always being
sort of murderous when they're up there
i mean look at it it's like sheep rodeo
[Music]
oh now this is fascinating
so we've got two juveniles here and one
adult and i can tell that because the
the fleshy bits around the eye and the
fleshy bit at the base of the beak is
yellow in juveniles and gets darker the
older that they get
god they're silly
play is a way of not just enjoying your
environment but learning about it and
you know it's always good to have a toy
that your friends don't have
it's been shown that the calls they make
when they're playing like laughter in
that they're infectious to the other
cares around them so when they're making
the sounds of play and another kia hears
it they will they'll play harder and
longer
just like you know encouraging each
other i suppose
these cocky alpine parrots have made a
life for themselves in a place where no
other parrot can live
i think it's because they're fearless
and despite the fact that it can be a
little gory the kia is definitely
extraordinary
[Music]
so there you go
five of the world's most extraordinary
wild animals now you might be surprised
at how smart some of them are or how
sneaky or perhaps you might just like
laughing along with their antics but the
truth is that just like us animals are
extraordinary in a million different
ways
[Music]
hey thanks for watching and make sure
you subscribe to abc science if you
enjoyed this video because we have
videos like this every single week and
on top of that look for abc science on
social media and even me because i'd
like to say hello catch you next time